I don't think competency is the driving
Factor but I I see the calculation a
little differently I think that what we
need is the person who can get elected
right like if you want Joe Biden out and
I do I've been open about it for the
reasons I stated you have to go with
whoever is most likely to do that and I
know that Nikki Haley supporters think
it's her and Ronda Santa supporters
think it's him but my calculation is
somebody who would take any of those
guys or gals is you got to get the one
who who can bring together the the
biggest Coalition and the Trump
Coalition is never leaving Trump they're
just not going to leave him so I think
the rest of the Coalition is probably
going to migrate over to them because
they're
immovable I just see that as their
reality So eventually the rest they're
just going to have to bend to the Trump
coalition's will because the Trump
voters are not getable that some 25 to
35% depending on you know who you
believe they're just never going to move
and the Republicans need to
win I'm Dave Ruben this is the Ruben
report and you know what this woman just
does not need an introduction Megan
Kelly my friend and and actual I'm going
to consider you a journalist I'm not
sure that's what you consider yourself
anymore hello how are you my friend
hi I'm good how you doing Dave I'm all
right I'm all right I think it's
actually uh perfectly fitting to have
you on the show this week we were
supposed to do this a couple weeks ago
and then I think both our schedules went
a little wacky but to have you on uh
today obviously right in the middle of
this Israel Hamas thing uh and just sort
of really what I want to focus on I
guess and then we can you know me we can
talk about whatever you want to talk
about is sort of like the media reaction
to this and how we're seeing like a new
type of War unfold online and if it
wasn't for for Twitter right now and you
know if it was the old days for you back
at your corporate job at Fox how maybe
you'd have to cover it differently or
even at NBC during that stint um so
maybe kind of take it from there like
well first off what do you make of the
last couple days just kind of broadly
and then we'll kind of try to narrow
it you know it reminds me of like 2015 I
think that's the right year when Isis
was getting really aggressive in the
Middle East and you'd go on the air at
night and ask yourself can I repeat any
of this can I show any of this video
this is so beyond the pale it's so evil
we're not going to show them burning
people alive in cages we're just not
going to do that and there were certain
lines that you wouldn't cross as a news
organization you know on cable and I'm
having that same feeling now like can
you show the the the absolute rape and
murder and torture of human beings in
Israel can you what should we and I've
been watching my friends in the media
make their own decisions in our digital
Lane which has different rules now you
know you you do have more freedom if you
make the editorial choice to show it and
we've been debating it internally it's
we can show it it's just there's only so
much the human heart can take you know
there's I don't know I'm sure you
because I know you've got people you
love there um but even I as somebody
who's got more distance between me and
and Israel and the actual events but
just a supporter of Israel have been
walking around with just such a heavy
heart over the past few days it's
affecting everything it's affecting the
way I'm interacting with my family with
my friends you know my my sleeping
that's with all the distance in the
world between me and the events every
inch closer and it's even harder so at
some point I do think over here we've
been showing some of the tapes not all
you know you have to make a decision to
protect yourself and your well-being and
be able to report on it you know without
feeling the heaviness of it other wise
you can't get through it you saw that
reporter the Israeli reporter today
trying to report you know as a
professional on the babies you know a
phrase I don't I don't know if any it's
ever been uttered before in the in news
coverage anywhere decapitated babies I I
don't know if anybody had ever even
considered that horror and then you find
40 like how do you go on with your life
how do you do anything other than take
up arms against these people and so I
fully understand what I am seeing online
with people saying Gaza must be raised
that's it there should be no more Gaza
it should look like a parking lot when
Israel is done with it that is how I
feel too and the only thing that would
dissuade me from that feeling is if it's
going to lead to more Destruction for
Israel and her allies you know if it's
going to provoke Iran or Hezbollah even
more and cause more headaches for Israel
because that to me seems like the only
quote
proportionate response to what's being
done yeah proportionate I've really come
to hate that word it's a
disproportionate response it's oh so you
murdered and raped and burned and
beheaded our children and our women and
everything else let's say a thousand
could we get a thousand of your people
so we can proportionately do those same
things I mean how much of this now that
you're on this side on the media side
where you fully I I know that every
well even when you were on Fox I know
you personally so I know everything was
coming out of you Megan Kelly yourself
and you were saying what you believed
but now in the total freedom to do this
the way you want and have those
conversations with your guys about how
how much of this can we show and how
much can I deal with and everything else
um how different is that than maybe when
you were in the corporate side of
things I mean I will say that when I was
at Fox they were very pro-israel and
they were never hesitant to show what
was being done to Israel by by its
enemies Hamas included so I never felt
constrained there and certainly when
Isis was enacting its its
atrocities we didn't show everything
it's just again it's just too much and
and there are rules on cable um but we
showed a lot and we we didn't go easy on
them at NBC I was lucky enough not to
have this kind of thing pop up in my
very limited time there nor would they
be have been expecting the 9900 a.m.
show to do it so I wasn't forced into
this kind of decision making um so I
think that's fortunate for me I'm seeing
it more right now with the mainstream
media and the choices they're Mak the
the editorial choices they're making
yeah they're going and have gone exactly
the same way that we saw them go during
BLM during these other you know massive
conflicts that have divided us and this
just shouldn't be one this just this
just shouldn't be one this should just
be like there's a reason Joe Biden
sounds for the most part like you and me
right now it was it was shocking few
things it was shocking it was right
before we're taping this yeah yeah where
we would all sound the same now we can
talk about his remarks and I don't think
he went far enough but he his core
message was a good one and I agreed with
what he was saying where what's
happening where you and Mark lvin and I
and the guy who runs uh you know the ADL
the green black guy all agree but the
the Washington Post and Forbes and all
the college campus groups are saying
something very different it's like the
media and the academy that's been
co-opted by the wokest of the woke and
as we've known for some time that
doesn't include Jews it doesn't include
Jewish people as Barry Weiss once put it
to me we don't rate we don't count we're
not on the list of protected classes
even though we are technically a
protected class right well you can't
have a minority that succeeds it breaks
the entire intersectional calculator
they they like their minority is on
their knees basically forever I mean
that that's kind of how it works
um coming from I just want to hit the
mainstream media thing one more time
because I think we're I actually think
that this moment is like to me it's it's
actually causing a massive shift almost
the final shift in what we needed where
the mainstream media will not be
relevant anymore and the online will be
but I'm also a little concerned because
you know there's an awful lot of people
who talk for a living that have no idea
what they're talking about and know
nothing about history and have huge
audiences and confuse people either
intentionally or not what do you think
we do about that like we can do the we
can bash mainstream media all day long
and this or that but what do we do about
this other thing where it's like you're
pretty damn good and you're one on the
short list of people I trust and I guess
a couple people like me but like we're
not perfect and now people are going to
anybody that has a webcam which is
basically everybody well and on you know
X formerly known as Twitter it's a
similar problem in that now that it's
been monetized and you get more money if
you've signed up for that which I
haven't um you get more money if you get
more engagement so it's in your interest
to just be as provocative as possible
and you line in your pockets that way so
that's problematic I mean I'm I'm a
capitalist I'm not against people making
money but I the system is set up in a
fraught way and you could argue the same
is true RIT large you know cable news
does better if it bleeds it leads that
kind of thing um and so you have to find
ideally somebody who I mean you've done
very well I've done very well I I don't
need this paycheck in order to survive I
I need my Integrity to look at myself in
the mirror every morning so you have to
find a person like that doesn't have to
be me or you but you have to figure out
whether this person's there for dollars
or whether they're an honest broker and
whether they tell you the things you
don't want to hear even when it hurts
what you know is the anchor or the
host's side right that's how I would
make my decision but on something this
complex you really do need to be choosy
about where you get your info I mean
most of these anchors on CNN
or MSNBC forget that are you know a
bunch of twits who have absolutely no
education on any of this stuff and are
too lazy to do their homework they they
want to be Stars Dave they don't want to
actually be your guide through something
as complex as the Israeli Palestinian
relationship they don't want to do a
deep dive on Hamas and Gaza and what
happened in 2005 and what happened you
know what who started bombing who first
and why and why the blockade was put
into they don't care they want what gets
them clicks and what get you click
amongst the young people today is to say
that Israel is a
colonialized and that they're the
oppressor and that you're on the side of
the oppressed because that's what's hip
today you're a BLM and they're oppressed
and you're on the side of the lgbtq
people because they're the oppressors
they're not aggressors and therefore
you're on the side of the Palestinians
SL Hamas the poor Hamas oppressed people
who live in the new term quote an open a
prison gays for Palestine is very
different than Palestine for gays that's
what I always tell everybody it's like
it's like come on come on just just a
simple Google search would help you out
so much before you these idiotic posts
young people yeah God does does it seem
to you in a way that that the reason we
got to this moment was not just well
putting aside like there are genocidal
organizations and there's hate and like
that kind of stuff but this moment now
where we're at with media and where
we're at with confusing children about
their gender and where we're at with
open borders like all of the stuff that
this was obviously going to be where we
were going to get to at some point like
that's what I've been feeling the last
couple days like suddenly it's here it
feels like something new is here and
I've sort of been just like oh of course
we were going to get here what did you
think you know when I see the Hamas
rallies in New York in Times Square it's
like well of course that was going to
happen if you have open borders and you
don't defend your culture and all of
those things and maybe that makes me
sound like crazy right-wing Mark liin
now but but here we are that's obviously
sarcasm no and it's it's it's a good
point I've been thinking about I had to
go through my phone recently and um I
had to find this old picture of my now
14-year-old son like a baby picture so
it required me to scroll through what
you're going through right now right all
the baby all the fun baby videos and on
there was a video of my daughter who was
six when Trump was elected and my
daughter at the time did not like Trump
because as she put in her little video
he he bullied my mom that's how she she
was sick I think I always said to you
you get like a full pass and I'll I'll
grant that pass to your daughter as well
so she's come around but at the time she
was not his fan and she was saying in
this in this little piece um he
shouldn't be president can you change
presidents right and so she wasn't his
fan and honestly for some reason that
like every time I look at Joe Biden that
is what I think right now he shouldn't
be president can you change presidents
like how soon could we get Donald Trump
Ronda santis Nikki Haley r i don't give
it down any of them how soon can we get
them in there because you can feel us
losing it like all of it by the second
you know like you say from from the very
simple premise that we don't hurt our
children we don't voluntarily allow our
children to cut off body parts and
sterilize themselves and become
essentially asexual when they're 15
because they're going through a phase we
don't we don't do that that's something
only lunatics would do and we certainly
protect our border to the point where we
don't have cities overrun with migrants
and like New York where you have to get
a translator for every single language
that appears in your publicly funded
school where you've paid your taxes and
they haven't and now your kids's got to
wait in a line for an hour to enter the
classroom where then he he will be told
about sexuality and ask whether he
really is a she and given a book about
that you only want him to get
through the third grade without reading
like that's that's our country and then
you walk out in a Time Square from this
public city school and you see baby
having been beheaded in Israel and the
next thing you see is some group
chanting like gas the Gaye or gas the
jeice it's the same I don't who knows
right you get what wait what right so
it's very jarring and you and I have
something in in common which is we try
to maintain our sense of humor yeah this
has been critical to staying a well
person and staying I think in this Lane
that we're in and still wanting having
people want to listen to us because it
can't be all dark and awful
and in these moments it's very hard to
laugh you know when you uh you came and
you did the uh on my book tour you did
the show in West niak which was one of
the best nights of the entire tour
because it was you and it was the new it
was the one New York show which was my
home I once lived in New York before I
lived in the Free State of Florida and
um you you described me on stage as a
happy warrior and I guess I never really
thought of myself that way but I think
that I ultimately am and I have to say
in doing my show this week I this is the
hardest it has ever been in my life I
mean I literally on Monday I walked out
of the studio and I cried like what do
you do you ever find that like how do
you how did it be that Megan Kelly ended
up being one of the people that is going
to make sense of the world in a time
where no one's making any sense like
like for you deep like personally how it
became you I mean it's very hard the
these day days and weeks are very very
hard um but I do think it's important to
not forget your Humanity I know I told
the story in my book and I I told it for
a reason but there was a moment after on
on 911 where on Good Morning America it
was Diane Sawyer and Charlie Gibson
anchoring and as the tower went down the
first Tower went down Charlie Gibson had
the glasses at the end of the nose and
was the network anchor and just
continued reporting the tower appears to
have fallen you know the number of the
loss of life will be significant and and
Diane Sawyer said oh my God
and it was a lesson you know he
regretted his response and wished it had
been more like hers she didn't forget
her Humanity in the moment she did go on
to report all those things that he was
saying and maintained her
professionalism but in these moments
it's okay to to still be a human being
and I actually think it's important to
still be a human being like
yesterday we opened the show with a
description of what the latest was you
know the the horrors at it Israel and
I'll just tell you the truth after the
show is over we always do like a you
know a postgame meeting with the team
and I was critical of the way we set up
the show because we did this very tug
aty heartstrings intro all of which was
true and real and proper and then we
went went right to Ted Cruz who I like
but what Ted Cruz really wanted to talk
about was politics and the B
Administration all of which was good but
what we needed was a moment to sigh and
think and reflect and talk about how we
were feeling just a minute you don't
have to spend an hour but just a minute
instead of getting right to the heart
the hardness of it all and and I do
think those moments are what help us
remain happy Warriors Dave you know it's
like you can't go right to anger on any
of these stories you do have to spend
some time in your humanity and allow the
feelings to be felt and then find a way
through you you don't you don't deal
with it unless you go through it
do you think we will like do you now
think we're just in this for a while
like do do you sense that sort of shift
that I'm talking about in the world that
like I I just don't think that this
thing's going away for a while I don't
even mean just the specifics of the
violence I mean just like whatever it is
now unearthing I I sense we're in it for
a while and then you throw it a
presidential election which is still 13
months away I mean everyone thinks it's
tomorrow and it's 13 months away like it
seems to me we're now stuck for a
bit Yeah I think for a bit but I I am
very hopeful that a change in leadership
at the top can change things I really I
am now look I'll be honest um Trump
brings with him such a bag of you know
baggage that that will add a new level
of chaos to it all there's just no
question about that so I do think
another Republican leader would probably
bring less less of that chaos
but who who's kidding whom like if
president Trump were in the office right
now do do any of us believe this would
have happened I don't believe that no no
as critical as
yeah no 100% I'm with you yeah we
wouldn't have had Afghanistan and I
realize he wanted to withdraw from
Afghanistan but I don't believe for one
second that he would have done it the
way that Joe Biden did it and I think he
would have changed his mind if he had
seen any sort of wobbling uh by the
afghanis on the Defense Force but so I
don't think we would would have had
Afghanistan I don't think we would have
had Russia and Ukraine and I don't think
we would have had this atrocity with
Hamas and I do think Trump's instability
you know in messaging in temperament
when it came to foreign policy was a
benefit to us you know Rick grenell
tells the story of how Angela Merkel
looked in his eyes and said like I don't
know what's your guy's going to do next
and he had to stop himself from smiling
you know and and bombing sulamani the
Iranians didn't know what to do they
were afraid they were like holy
right bomb sulamani and they were too
weak and too afraid of him and us to do
anything in response so right everyone
said it was going to of the guy right
everyone said it was going to start
World War II and it gave us actually
three years of peace and how many mid
east peace deal
and the rest of it so so all of this DAV
is by by way of saying I I am optimistic
that we can regain stasis that we can
regain a steadiness that has been
missing for the past couple of years and
I'm pretty sure that what we're feeling
right now is akin to what our parents
were feeling in the 70s after a couple
of years under Jimmy Carter that
instability starts at a very high level
and trickles down he's been pushing all
this he opened the Border he's
allowing this myth about boys becoming
girls and rewarding it being taught in
schools he's pushing the racial
essentialism and dividing us from you
know K through 12 and Beyond in the
classroom he and his allies in Academia
even Corporate America and Beyond are
are festering allowing to Fester these
lies which are dividing us and making us
feel disconnected patriotism on the way
down religious observance on the way
down and the weakness being projected on
the on the foreign policy front I really
think a lot of it starts with the
American president and it was a severe
mistake for Americans to put him in
office who who do you think is driving
that because I I think you basically
said this already you don't believe that
Biden's really driving the ship right
now there's some other you know everyone
has their own theory on this whether
it's Obama in a in a Biden costume or
it's the Obama people or just like some
version of something this does not seem
like Joe Biden is in charge I think
someone basically hands him notes he
pours reads them fumbles off the stage
and then we just do it again the next
day do do you have a sense of really
where this is coming
from I wish I knew I mean my best guess
is if it's not Obama himself it's all of
his disciples because that's who Joe
Biden hired uh and you remember that
that one appearance where Obama came
back to the White House and how the
entire staff ignored Biden and went
right over over to Obama unbelievable
that that was very telling but I I
really I wish I knew I don't think it is
Joe Biden and I don't think you know I I
go back to things like all of the
rewards that he's creating or trying to
create at the college level scholarships
and so on for people who write just the
perfect BLM message who who major in ebx
kendi nonsense you know he's doing this
he's trying that's not Joe Biden he's
the biggest racist elected to president
in I don't know good 25 years well we
got our clip for today's
show seriously I mean there's not the
week goes by five that he doesn't say a
new racist thing he's not pushing BLM
nonsense so who is that it's I think
it's the leftover woke obam crew I mean
look at Obama it's how long did it take
him 48 hours to even bother to put
together some anod tweet on these
atrocities like his heart wasn't in it
so I don't really know the answer Dave I
wish I did you know the closest I've
seen is that Easter Bunny who he really
seemed to listen to but I don't know
who's inside the costume that's what I'm
saying it's Obama in the Easter bunny
costume it really could be um yeah it's
just it's it's because it's also like
it's something that's dis it's why
everyone's going nuts basically that's
what I think is that we all know these
things that are so obvious like Joe
Biden's not running it and that boys
actually are boys and girls girls but
we're so hit with these things and then
all the entire class of people who were
supposed to say you know say the truth
they all completely failed and then
we're just like oh yes beheading women
is okay because everything else is
broken why not like that's really where
I think we're at this is what's so crazy
I mean you that sounds like a laugh line
like you just taking something that
actually happened and making an
absurdity out of it that actually is
happening like the the women the babies
they are being murdered they are being
beheaded the elderly ladies sitting and
waiting for the bus are being shot
multiple time by machine guns and
they're posting the pictures online and
then Washington Post journalists are
liking tweets that say what did you
think decolonization meant yeah did you
think it meant Vibes losers that
happened her name is Karen AA she writes
for the Washington Post I follow her you
know why I follow her because she's a
BLM supporter she's with Kendy and
D'Angelo and all the lunatics but I like
to get the viewpoints of people who I
disagree with and she's one of them but
she seems like in her personal life kind
of a nice person she posts pictures of
her cat she posts pictures of her
workout she okay she expresses
insecurities from time to time she you
know and I I I do it for an intentional
purpose I like to remind myself that my
adversaries on policy or ideologically
are not necessarily evil you know
they're we disagree very strongly but
like I like to like some of her posts
about her cat Dave I don't have a cat
I'm a dog person but I'm just saying
like it makes me feel good that I can
still see the humanity in this person I
it's just my own personal private thing
this person liked the tweet from this
lunatic activist saying what I just said
about decolonization this is what it
looks like you're a loser if you don't
understand it okay babies are being
decapitated so you can right off
your cat and your Tweet it's over
unfollow this is the thing that was a
bridge too far for me I can understand
differences on all the other stuff and
it's it's not even about exactly the
Jewish thing it's about the humanity
thing you know like where is your
Humanity I don't get how you can look at
that beautiful group of Israelis dancing
at the Rave for peace that's what that's
what they said they were out there for
having a good time as like only a
22-year-old can do out under the Open
Sky and see them murdered
in the absolute not even the prime of
their life in the part of the life where
everything is yet to be enjoyed and say
haha that's a win yeah you go that I
don't have anything in common with those
people I can't like anything about them
in my own head it feels like it's War
it's on I you're
despicable you know no one ever gets to
the end of the argument and I think
Megan Kelly just got to the end of the
argument and it's so freaking refreshing
I didn't I didn't say the f bomb because
I've dropped it like 20 times on my show
in the last two days so I'm glad that
you handled it for me okay so so I get
you on those people but what do you
think we do about now we have what I
refer to as the Hamas caucus we have AOC
we have Rashida Talib we have ilhan Omar
and the rest of them um what's the other
one's name uh I got it yeah Cory Bush ET
yeah thanks she's such a faker at least
a couple of those are Palestinian
American Cory she's like living out of
her car and posting BLM slogans 2
minutes ago now she wants us to look at
her as an authority on Israel Palestine
sure sure oh sure Jan okay but what do
we do about these people look I you know
how I feel about Free Speech but I think
we are getting perilously close where if
you constantly defend people who are
calling for genocide and murder and
beheading babies and everything else and
always excusing it and then you connect
that to the people that are in Times
Square calling for all these things and
showing Nazi Flags we're I don't think
this is exactly the neo-nazis marching
in skoki Illinois and the uh NAACP
standing up for them anymore I I don't
think that's where we're at I think
we're veering into something else what
do you think what do we do about this do
you think their allegian is to the
Constitution that they sore to
protect um I I'll say this my first
instinct is I like that they're posting
these tweets it completely exposes them
in a way that you know few other like
they done controversial things it's been
pretty clear people like Anan Omar are
anti-semites for a long time if you've
been paying attention but this is just
so clear like it's kind of good to see
them posting these statements and really
taking away all doubt it's wonderful
actually now we'll always have these
statements we can always dismiss all of
their arguments because we understand
that these are vile people um and
anybody who is persuadable will agree
with us anybody who doesn't agree with
us we know that they're in the club too
they're also anti-semites there's
absolutely no reason to support what
they're saying right now so I kind of
like the fact that they have a forum and
that they're being exposed I find it
much more problematic at the
universities that we have hundreds and
hundreds of students coming forward to
blame Israel for all of it yeah like
that's that is I mean that's that's what
Harvard says Harvard says we raised
tomorrow's leaders and they're not
entirely wrong and for them to have 31
student groups blaming Israel for all of
this and it's not just Harvard Stanford
Berkeley Yale Northwestern George
Washington I could keep going putting
out statements and then in some of these
cases the university President says
nothing in response we're seeing it like
at the lower at the high school level
too uh students coming out who Don't
Know Jack trying to make supportive
statements of Palestine of Hamas they
they don't know what they're doing so
that actually is problematic to me
because those people are going to move
into positions of power real power the
squad is marginalized for all of the bad
she did Nancy Pelosi kept them
marginalized and that was one win in the
Pelosi file and they're still
marginalized they're just such a small
group and I just think it's not totally
without value to have them squawking so
people who are sane can point to them
and say is that what you want to sign up
for is that is that what being a
Democrat is they serve some purpose yeah
you know you're probably giving a
much I would say cleare eyed account
than than I'm giving of them because I
think you're probably right and I have
shared some of their stuff purely with
the attention of okay here they are all
right this is them you know what are we
going to do we're not going to jail them
here we go but uh I you know I don't
want to get too much into the uh the
Trump Dan santis thing and all that but
I do want to ask you a little bit about
your your interview with Trump because
it was spectacular I've told you that
privately and publicly but also because
he went after you personally years ago
your daughter did not like him and now
has I guess come around a bit um but
she's openminded can you fair enough
Fair well that makes her a crazy
right-winger you know how it is um but
can you talk a little bit about how you
go into that room like what you're
thinking like a minute before knowing I
I just know you you wanted Challenge on
the right things and you did but you
also don't want it to be the last time
you ever sit down with him and there's
always that weird moment with him where
it could go in either direction could
you just talk just like your philosophy
more than about like the specifics of
the
politics well I knew going in there
before I even arrived at Bedminster his
Golf Club in New Jersey where he was
that it would probably one be one and
done that if I were going to do my duty
as a journalist it was going to be one
and done because he just doesn't allow
ongoing access unless you
kiss his ass you know that's kind of the
way it is with Trump and that's fine he
can set the terms you know like it's
kind of that's how it is okay you go in
knowing that so my goal was not to
please Trump because to please Trump I
would have had to abandon my
journalistic duty but my goal was also
not I'm G to kill Trump I'm going to
emerge with Trump's jugular you know
this is it since it's one and done I'm
gonna crush him I'm gonna unleash all my
aame and you know try to take him out no
that wasn't it either I wanted to do
like a lively interesting challenging
but also informative interview with him
one that would have something for
everybody so I felt when it was over
that I did you know there was stuff that
Maga really liked his Reflections on
whether this is worth it you know like
what he could be doing instead of this
his Reflections about his family his
thoughts on Joe Biden the difference
between age and competence and all that
um stuff that would be there for you
know people like you who who are going
to vote Republican probably but don't
want Trump you know Trump's the nominee
I'm voting for him obviously I mean it
goes to that question exactly um and
then you know stuff not not for the
Liberals but stuff that would be
important to any objective interview
like his legal troubles you know and and
that was one of my irritants as a
journalist is just I haven't seen
anybody done do a good job of
challenging him on the legal troubles
and it's really been bothering me and I
knew I had to do it and I knew he
wouldn't like it and sure enough I was
right what was the part there were a
couple moments in there that went viral
because you did end up again not because
you were trying to get him but you did
get him on a couple things I mean the
gender one you asked the most basic
question how their differences between
boys and girls and he like fumbled for a
good five seconds and then offered this
like odd sort of I guess so answer if a
woman can give birth which obviously
does not decide gender because there are
obviously women who cannot give birth um
like was that the weirdest one for you
or was there something else was it more
on the legal stuff or on the I was
surprised that he didn't did not have a
better answer for can a man become a
woman sometimes the simplest questions
are the hardest ones you know and he he
definitely got caught on that one which
wasn't a trick question you know I did
not intend for it to be a trick question
um the legal stuff I really wanted to
press him a little because he continues
to just say I'm covered by the
presidential records act I'm covered I'm
covered I'm covered and I just I you
know as a lawyer I understand exactly
the whole argument the law and where the
pitfalls are and he you could see when
when I had him to Trump's credit he was
smart he knew when I had him and he'd go
to I'm not going to answer that so he's
getting smarter about Not Giving too
much ammo you know to reporters or by
extension prosecutors in these
interviews he's smart I mean Trump is
definitely very smart um so I knew he
wasn't going to like that stuff but he
needed to be asked those questions and I
would say the one that sort of I was
laughing about most after it was over
was his obsession with my debate
question from 2015 still
still get over it it's been eight years
move on you can't I mean your daughter
has moved on so it's time it's time to
move on what would you make of of the
argument because you know there was a
clip when I I think you were on my show
maybe a year ago and we were talking
about the Trump to santis thing that
seemed like it was going to shake out
and it went really viral because you
basically were like look it's Trump
because nobody can defeat that monster
and I basically said you might be right
I still think you might be right but it
seems to me that that right now at this
moment for having everything we just
talked about we need someone like just
like hyper competent and clear and no BS
that can deliver the message without the
and all of that stuff and it's
very obvious to me there's a guy that
can do that uh you did interview him by
the way too Dan santis it took a little
while and you were critical of him
beforehand and and he did it as well do
you think enough people care about
competency anymore and maybe that's part
of everything that we've discussed here
in terms of the collapse of all the
stuff that really we kind of just do
want the reality show and not the
competent one so we'll get exactly what
we
deserve I don't think competency is the
driving Factor but I I see the
calculation a little differently I think
that what we need is the person who can
get elected right like if you want Joe
Biden out and I do I've been open about
it for the reasons I stated you have to
go with whoever is most likely to do
that and I know that Nikki Haley
supporters think it's her and Ronda
Santa supporters think it's him but my
calculation is somebody who would take
any of those guys or gals is you got to
get the one who who can bring together
the the biggest Coalition and the Trump
Coalition is never leaving Trump they're
just not going to leave him so I think
the rest of the Coalition is probably
going to migrate over to them because
they're
immovable I just see that as their
reality So eventually the rest they're
just going to have to bend to the Trump
coalition's will because the Trump
voters are not getable that some 25 to
35% depending on you know who you
believe they're just never going to move
and the Republicans need to win so if
they want to win I even think like you
know the establishment Republicans sort
of the Reagan Library Republicans the
Chamber of Commerce like they're like we
can't stand that we're in this position
we don't want Trump and then the only
thing we hate more than Trump is Biden
so these guys on their motor motorcycles
and in their trucks are going to drag us
on over there and we're going to have to
vote for the orange man again and my
position on the outside where I am just
watching it all is okay I guess we're
going to go this way again it's fine as
long as we don't stay on the path we're
on which I see is the most deadly
destructive possible path you know look
it's obvious I don't hide anything here
I obviously think that Dan santis would
be the best chief executive to get us
out of this and you know I just saw him
this morning at a synagogue in Miami and
it's like the guy speaks you know he
he's not the most entertaining speaker
but he speaks from the heart with no
notes and with Clarity and knows history
and all of those things I was like that
guy as I'm watching him that guy should
be the president but if at the end of
this Trump is the president and Dan
santis is my
Governor all right like it would be okay
with me you know what I mean like it
would be okay but you know you mentioned
the Reagan Library I I was there what
was it 10 days ago or so for that debate
it was basically a show from top to
bottom from the moderators uh and I I
consider Dana a friend you I'm sure you
know her from your Fox days like but
just like the entire thing felt like it
was from 1994 if the Simpsons had done a
parody of what a republican debate would
be right like did you watch it thinking
man none of this man like you give me
Megan Kelly and and Reuben and throw in
Michael malice or whoever you want to be
like as the moderators and and people
might have learned something including
the people on the stage like is that
Machinery just completely broken and
calcified and and done but they just
won't throw it was that night I wouldn't
say it's it's done as a as a as a
mechanism I think it could still work
but it didn't that night I mean there
were so many things that were wrong
moderators had no control it's not to
say that it's easy but you should at
least try you're not there to serve the
presidential candidates you're there to
serve the audience you're the traffic
cop do it do it sorry you may not like
your job you may think you you might
seem a little rude but that's part of
the art of it is sort of trying to
thread that needle between being
respectful of the audience at home and
making sure that the candidat can be
heard and not being you know too
overbearing and acting like you know a
bully who everybody hates um I don't
think any of them had ever hosted a
presidential debate before and it showed
um the the woman from Univision was
embarrassment yeah and and it was F like
I don't know why Fox agreed to partner
with Univision I really don't it was
people are online saying oh no they
didn't have any choice it was the RNC
that's not true I'm here to tell you
that's not how it works oh interesting
Fox 100% could have said we're not going
to partner with them who do you think
was paying for that debate you think it
was Univision it wasn't it was Fox News
which has more money than everybody and
so it was Fox News is money and I'm sure
Univision paid some small poultry amount
to sort of partner on it and it was
would have been up to Fox as the Big
Money Maker payer to say we don't want
them we we want somebody else there's a
million place you could do the Wall
Street Journal like they did on debate
number one there's a lot of conservative
Outlets you could part to a Daily Caller
what have you probably wouldn't because
it's Tucker whatever there's a lot um
they chose them and then they let let
this woman run wild and she ruined their
debate that lunatic ruined their debate
yeah um and and by the way you know it's
like Dana and Stuart
like better than the Univision lady but
I'll just leave it at that that that
that question about like the Survivor it
was beneath the D the Dignity of the of
the debate of the candidates of the
anchors I don't understand how it didn't
wind up in the editing room floor um and
I'll tell you it's like both of these
debates that we've watched so far have
made me say the same thing
um which is forgive me because it's it's
a little self-aggrandizing but I miss
Brett Chris Wallace and yours truly yeah
sitting down together and coming up with
the toughest best but most OnPoint
debate questions we could and the way we
used to do it was we would split it up
into the three the amongst the three of
us we would choose our subjects because
we all had our favorites you know like
Brett always liked foreign policy I
always love social issues uh Wallace
always liked economic issues so we never
really fought over who's going to do
what and you sort of have your first
choice and then you divide the second
choices anyway it always worked out then
you go back to your respective dens and
you'd work out the toughest questions
you could and the Brain room at Fox
would give you all the background
information you needed on your favorite
issues in your in your candidates and
then you'd meet and you'd come up with
here's what I here's my list here's
where I've gone and the other two would
just murder board your questions not
tight enough too weak too easy too BL
too nasty too not nasty enough and and
then the debate team Bill Sam and Chris
diral those are dirty names now amongst
some of the hardcore Maga crew because
they were behind the Arizona call oh
decent honest journalist Fox never
should have gotten rid of them anyway
they they challenge even more they'
tighten it up even even tougher and so
by the time you got out there you had
these gleaming sharp beautiful questions
that had come from your heart and your
brain but it had been Polished by a
whole team of people you respected and
when I asked my question or Chris asked
his question or Brett asked his question
the three of us would be beaming with
pride because we all had a hand in it in
some way shape or form and we all
trusted the others to not back down and
to be strong and to be a good
representative of Fox News and of the
audience watching and all I can tell you
is I've been sorely missing that whole
thing how many of those did you do five
yeah man give it to Megan Kelly I I'll
I'll send the letter to somebody I don't
know that anyone's responding to my
letters let me ask you something else
that I think it just popped in my head
as you were saying something this is
probably more what I would ask you
offline but we're on camera why not do
you when you have all these
relationships with these people the
politicians and then the other pundits
and the talking heads and all of that do
you find at times it can be tough
because I this is just personally what I
found now is that because I'm F friendly
at least with so many of these people
and know them and have played basketball
with them or had them over for dinner
whatever sometimes there's this piece in
me where I want to not criticize someone
as much as I should or I at least have
to think about it in a different way or
or you don't want to say something about
a certain politician because then they
won't do your show like how do you
balance all of that because you've been
on both sides of this mainstream and now
this side you've interviewed everybody
you basically know everybody I've never
heard anyone say a bad word about you
except maybe some people at MBC so like
you know like how do you balance all of
that and still um maintain
Integrity I have very few friends you're
on a very short list my friend oh that's
nice realize how valuable this this
friendship was to me no I have a very
short list I I don't fraternize with
them if they're politicians I don't
fraternize with them you know it's I'll
give you one example I'll give you two
examples um V ramaswami first came into
my life as somebody who knew Jed
rubenfeld of Yale law school who's a
brilliant professor and they'd been
co-writing pieces for the Wall Street
Journal uh editorial page or opets and
uh on legal issues and I was like oh
these are good legal issues they were
getting at sort of the erosion of free
speech and I know Jed a bit he's married
to am chew a tiger mom oh oh right right
of course yeah yeah I bet so I knew them
a little and so I got to know V and I
started he WR books I started reading
his books and he'd ask me for comment
what I know him a bit like him fine I
would fraternize with v then he decided
to run for office it's done it's off
we're not friends sorry we're
adversarial that's the only way I can do
my job honestly um you it's fine I I'm
not like your enemy now yeah but it I'm
going to hit you I'm going to hit you
repeated if you do dumb things or things
I I I think are dumb or worthy of
challenge not to say I'm the ultimate
Arbiter but I am of my show and um it
can't be that friendly anymore it just
can't be so you kind of know he's
running for office this is not the end
of our personal friendship but it's
definitely going to be on pause for a
long time and then my second example is
um Donald Trump when um he was a
celebrity and you know on TV he used to
come on Fox he was great he always rid
he was fun to talk to to he I he invited
me to a couple of these Celebrity
Apprentice things which I went to he was
always very gregarious you know he walk
in he'd give you the big hug and kiss
and like a it was tough not to like
Trump and then he decided to run for
president and he invited me to go down
to maralago you've got to see it it's so
beautiful sent me all these pictures of
it I was like hell no I am not going to
maralago the guy is running for
president guess what a lot of other
journalists did not make the same choice
voice then he found out that I was going
on a girls trip and we were going to
stay at Trump I know one of his hotels
and um he tried to pay for it he he
reached out to say where are you staying
I'll take care of it oh very nice right
quotes it's not nice and I said
absolutely not thank you very much Mr
Trump we'll pay for our own hotel and I
said to Abby my assistant make sure you
hold on to the records you know like
they this is what politicians try to do
and humans try to do do it too it's one
thing for Donald Trump celebrity to try
to woo me over to liking him that's less
fraught but politician Donald Trump has
to receive a hard no in response to all
those overtures and Dave that night I
went on to the debate stage August 6
2015 and asked him that very hard
question there were lots of hard
questions just that one that everybody
remembers you know what I had behind my
notes in addition to my outline and my
fact checks which are 10 Deep and I was
ready to back up everything I asked I
had the receipts from that Trump Hotel
visit and my rejection of his invitation
to go to Mara Lago because I didn't want
anybody using that against me same as
I'll have to do it to V ramaswami if he
ever tries to say you did you know like
it's just it gets very complicated when
you have to cover them objectively so I
think you know you either have to choose
or you have to just be very open about
your bias you know like I know you're a
disantis guy you've been open about that
so I think you're okay there but if you
have too many of those with with
politicians it can get dicey quickly
yeah and for sure you know for just from
from my perspective like the politician
version I don't have that much of it you
know I I played basketball with Ted Cruz
or I played video games with him we're
like some of that stuff but we're not
like friends like that I think for me
it's more like the pundit class where I
see guys that that are like kind of
doing what we do and then they kind of
go completely off the deep end and I'm
like H do I have to call you out it's
more that I think for me than yes well
you have and the answer is yes you do
you have to do and like you I have my my
short friend list so can I've got to
tell you one other
um so couple years back there's this guy
his name is Carlos Watson he invites me
to go on his YouTube show never heard of
Carlos Watson like who is he Abby's like
I don't know but you're sandwiched in
between it was like LeBron James and
Bill Gates so I'm like who is this guy
like he's got access to some very big
names um and I don't remember what the
Forum was on but it was on a big was
like election night and uh so I'm like
okay I'll do it she's like he's got all
these followers the show is very
successful okay so I I did it Carlos was
a perfect gentleman very nice guy solid
interviewer had a good time then I went
on a couple more times fine eventually
I'm like you know what I launched my
show I'm like I'll have them on had them
on very nice kind of kgy about like what
his background was he didn't want to
talk about his life but that's fine some
people are like that then he wanted me
to go to his Azie Fest was like uh you
know like one of those media things like
Jordan has you know everybody goes okay
I'm like I don't know then I see the
list of everybody who's going it's like
all these amazing names people I respect
people I
know I'm like all right you know I'll
look into it then the next thing I
see Carlos and Azie media are under SEC
investigation for impersonating a
Youtube CEO the the officer the chief
executive or COO of the company as
Goldman Sachs was trying to figure out
whether it was going to give Aussie
another business loan and wanted to kick
the tire and see if those YouTube
numbers were real well instead of
connecting them with the actual YouTube
his CFO faked being the YouTube
executive Li about their numbers the
whole thing Came Crashing Down it was a
house of cards that was all made up the
YouTube numbers were fake Carlos pretty
soon thereafter was under arrest the CFO
was under arrest Aussie Fest was off and
I'm thinking to myself it don't become
chummy with any of these people and I
went out on the air and I'm like I've
got something to tell you m in my
audience this guy who we had on not too
long ago and celebrated his independent
entrepreneurship he's a fraud according
to the government and several others
anyway it's just the whole business is
fraud and if you become friends with me
there's a 90% chance you're going to
wind up being a fraudster because that's
happened to me over and over Dave Ruben
uh excuse me Megan Kelly we are friends
we have shared tequila many times and uh
I am not a fraud and you are not a you
you actually I know I can say nice
things about you all the time but when
people always ask me Dave who do you
watch to make any sense of any of this
it's like it's basically you it's it's
you and Jordan for me and uh I thank you
for doing this as always and are you
going to come to why don't you come down
to Miami for the next debate we can have
tequila and you can yell at the uh the
moderators what do you think oh sure oh
I'd love to reconnect with my old Pals
from NBC I'll do it if you and I can sit
behind them with tomatoes yes that can
be arranged bitter party of one no two
we're more of an orange State we can
throw some oranges at him
it's done if you're looking for more
uncensored opinions from today's thought
leaders check out our media playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell